the Joe Rogan experience not long after
that in February in the middle of
February the caribou showed up that year
and I got five caribou at one time out
on the island on the lake and then you
know we were all set again we released a
famine yeah it is it's like a hungry
country but there are a lot of animals
but they just they're different places
you can fly over the Arctic all day long
and I see hardly anything yeah that's a
weird part about it right you would
think there's animals everywhere no
almost like a desert it is it's like the
Sahara Desert up there a lot of times
but there are a lot of animals
concentrated the caribou are contrary
this herds of a hundred thousand caribou
but 100,000 yeah at certain times a year
when they all congregate there can be a
hundred thousand that's insane
yeah some of the big some of the big
artic herds I mean they don't all get in
one place at one time
but there they are recognized as our
herd they get into the hundreds of
thousands mmm the very cyclic the
population goes up and down but you know
they're in there in certain places and
if they're not where you are you're in
the Sahara Desert then when they show up
it's like the Serengeti Plain I mean all
of a sudden there's caribou everywhere
you step outside you hear the antlers
all over the the valley if it's like in
October when they're rutting you hear
the wolves howl and Ravens croak and
it's like what the hell happened I
hadn't heard anything for the last two
months and all of a sudden look at that
oh my god yeah we're looking at an
enormous pack of caribou what do they
call them the compacts hurt herd
enormous herd of caribou look at all
those yeah it's in the summer not in the
summer they're up on the north side you
ha ha that's insane
it's so big still a nice neat huh I've
sat there at the cabin looking out at
the lake and caribou walking across the
lake moving all the time and I estimated
at one moment I could see 800 on the
lake Wow
yeah a lot of caribou like the way I
hunt them sometimes is to run around out
there on the lake with them
really yeah like um can you pull up a
picture on Facebook or you can't do that
this there's one of me running in a
caribou herd and you're not saying why
right on the front page there it's like
the pictures that you can leave up all
the time what do they call them not in
note section no it's right on the you
ran with them and that's how you were
hunting them echo chasing the car I told
you how I used to study a lot of
anthropology I used to listen to
anything that I could hear about how
people used to live in the old days and
especially the Inuit and people living
up north there was this this interposed
Austin Bullock see he made some films
back in 1960s of the Netsilik people the
Netsilik Eskimo series is called is
fascinating he went up Budhia Peninsula
in northern Canada and filmed people
that still knew how to do things in very
primitive ways and one thing I learned
from those films was how they would hunt
caribou and the way these people would
hunt caribou is there only be you know a
few hunters there build the little stone
inukshuks that comes like a scarecrow
make a line going down toward the lake
so it looks like people then the few
hunters would move around and they would
use their voice their yell and their
echo their voice around it confuse the
caribou and chase them into a lake that
way they could use their voice to get
them down there and then one guy in a
kayak can overtake the caribou and spare
them it's amazing but you of our self
yeah but this is something you can use
by yourself you can use this technique
of using your voice to confuse caribou
and heard them where you want them to go
you echo out on the lake if their
caribou it's wide open they can see me a
half a mile away and they'll go out in
the middle of a lake in the day and
stand around out there if I try walking
up to them a few hundred yards away they
might just take off yeah as loud as I
can yell and project my voice over to an
island or shoreline depending on where I
am and it'll bounce back and they'll
stop and they'll run straight back at me
Wow I've had him come running by me
where Tricia was like oh my god she
thought I was gonna get run over
she was filming once and I could hear
when I watched the video and she's like
oh I think he's gonna get run over you
know she's like really work you see that
picture there Jane it's it's right on
the yeah scroll up the top right there
the upper leftmost picture yeah okay
Trisha took that picture Wow so now
those caribou those caribou they were
running away from me before this picture
was taken and I screaming and hollering
echoing my voice off the shoreline and
they turn around and run back and I do
many times I had these caribou run back
and forth like five six times I could
stay within 50 yards and a lot of times
just by yelling as loud as I could
you look really close right there yeah
well
Trisha thaw is gonna get you know
trampled and so this is how you hunted
them this is a technique I've used for
hunting but on this particular day I was
just demonstrating it
[Applause]